if you're thinking about becoming an
architect there's lots of pros and cons
today i want to go through some of my
personal experience and
my thoughts
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and i'm a registered architect in
the state of western australia
if you're new here firstly thanks so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk about technology and architecture
so if that's something that interests
you make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below
like i mentioned today we're talking
about the pros and the cons of becoming
an architect
there are many on each side of the
battle but we want to start with the
pros today
so architecture is a very long road that
starts out at university
university is one of the craziest and
busiest times in your
whole architectural career in my
personal opinion because it is
just so full-on there is continuous
all-nighters for projects to get them
out the door
i think one of my worst was 48 hours
awake straight just to get a couple
projects out and i was somebody that was
extremely good with time management
so the fact that i was still up 48 hours
means everybody else was up for 50
60 70 hours straight to get some of
these major projects done
university is killer but it is an
amazing time you meet some amazing
people that will be lifelong friends and
colleagues
all the way through your professional
career as an architect you quickly
become the jack of all trades in
creativity
you're a completely creative person that
spends their time
just thinking abstractly and outside the
box most of the time you're never just
focused on one thing
you always have to juggle a few hence
the jack of all trades
eventually you become a little bit of a
master at engineering a little bit of
architecture
a little bit civil a little bit
structural and it just kind of mixes and
the flow comes together
everybody knows that the architect knows
almost everything
but also needs a lot of assistance so
don't get a big head as an architect
just because you've worked on a lot of
different projects
and know what should happen you still
should have to rely
on the professionals that you work with
if you think you were never bored at
university you'll also never get bored
in the real world
you're always juggling hundreds of
projects across one year
it's usually about 10 projects at any
given time
so for example you might be working on
five houses
three commercial buildings and two fit
outs they're all completely different
they all have different demands all have
different deadlines
so you're always under the pump trying
to juggle all these projects and
trying to satisfy everybody i know that
sounds like a bit of a con but we'll get
to that later
it is genuinely just a good time that
you're never bored at work because you
constantly have to think of other things
and different projects
in australia the word architect is a
protected title you have to be a
registered architect in australia to be
able to call yourself an architect
otherwise it is an offense so if
prestige honor and title are something
that you enjoy
then having the title of an architect is
definitely noteworthy
as an architect you get to improve many
many people's lives
everybody that comes into your office is
most of the time looking to better
themselves or their business
so in some way shape or form you are
pivotal in the next stage of their life
no matter what type of client walks
through your door they're all going to
be different
so you could have 10 identical projects
theoretically 10 residential houses
but every single client from their age
to their demographic
to their income is going to be
completely different and they're going
to need to be traded differently
so you're going to meet a whole range of
diverse people which is always exciting
to see the different walks of life
because you will have so many projects
most of the time you're going to have to
travel
quite a bit personally i have to travel
over a thousand kilometers every couple
of weeks
just to visit all of my clients so it is
very important
that you do enjoy travel and you're okay
with being away from home
otherwise this pro becomes a con very
quickly and i guess my final pro as
being an architect is that you're in
charge of a whole team
usually the architect is the leader of
the project it is on them
to navigate to manage and to coordinate
the whole process so you'll be directed
and directing at the same time
it is a hat that you juggle it is
another jack-of-all-trades skill that
you have to master
so you become very good at time
management you become very good at
navigating the minefield of people's
opinions
and you also know what opinions matter
to you and how you can progress with
those opinions
overall personally i still do believe
the pros outweigh the cons as an
architect
which i'm about to get onto now because
obviously i wouldn't still be an
architect
if i didn't believe that the pros
outweighed the cons
so moving on to the cons and starting
out where everybody does university
if you go to university to become an
architect sit there in day one and look
at your class
look at them very well because there is
a good chance 80 percent of that class
will not make it as an architect i
started my university degree with 600
students
alongside me by the time i got to my
fifth year and completed my master's
there was only about 40 people that
graduated alongside me
and to this day many years after i don't
keep in touch with that many people
so this statement is somewhat untrue but
the people i do keep in touch with i'm
the only registered architect at this
point in time
so having said that one from 600 people
is a very very tough gig to get through
and when you finally do find the job as
a graduate architect
which keeping in mind it is extremely
competitive because the guys that did
graduate
and girls are exceptionally good at
their jobs
so getting a job as a graduate architect
is incredibly difficult
then you go into the industry and you're
only making somewhere around the 50 000
mark in australia that barely covers
living expenses
so 50 000 is a very poor salary to start
on
nonetheless if you are good at your job
and you're able to prove yourself
your salary will go up so this isn't the
worst thing in the world
i know many blogs and many forums say
architects don't make a lot of money and
there is
very little chance of getting rich
however i find that
difficult to believe if you aren't good
at your job if you're good at your job
in any profession you'll make money and
you'll do well
so just keep that in mind when you read
all those blogs in all those forums
you might think you've graduated
university you've done your time you've
got a job
now you're an architect oh no there's
still a long road to go before you can
call yourself an architect
so another con of being an architect is
the journey to becoming an architect
is minimum seven to eight years
depending on how quickly you can finish
sections of your requirements and in
that seven to eight years it is
extremely stressful especially once you
come into the real world and into the
work life
work is always stressful there is 10 or
so jobs that you're juggling
at any given time like i mentioned
before there is hundreds of people
constantly emailing you asking you
questions
calling you at every time of day and
night it is
very very stressful but you do become
good at managing stress and managing
your time
and i guess the stress really comes down
to deadlines and the risk factor
you have constant deadlines from clients
saying i need this job done now i need
this job done now i need this job done
now i need this job done now
and you're just trying to please
everybody by getting it out to them as
quickly as possible
the risk as well is the fact that you
might miss something it might go to
construction
it might not meet the codes and
something might go horribly wrong
so it is your responsibility to make
sure everything is correct
in any set of documents that is leaving
your office to go for construction
now another big con of the architecture
profession is clients might walk into
your door
sign up get their first set of drawings
and then never pay
you could have done hours and hours and
hours of work and never see the
financial reward out of that and i guess
my final con for the day is the simple
fact that you are always criticized
architecture is the subjective field it
doesn't matter what you design
somebody's gonna hate it
so if you're uncomfortable with being
criticized if you're uncomfortable
with getting feedback that isn't always
positive
then unfortunately architecture probably
isn't for you
because as architects wake up criticism
every single day
there's award-winning designs out there
that people have hated
especially the very first one your
client sees the first presentation to
your client
trying to figure out what they really
want is very difficult and nailing that
the first time doesn't usually happen so
you have to be willing to take that
criticism on board and make things
better just because that's what that
person
truly wants anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below if you want
to know anything more about becoming an
architect or the architecture profession
leave a comment i'm happy to reply i try
to reply to as many people as possible
now because this video forms one of my
28 videos in 28 days
it would usually be i'll see you next
monday but in this case
i'll see you tomorrow